I'm going to introduce a basic
multiplication bar model
we'll start by reading the problem all
the way through and then we will restate
or a question in the form of a sentence
so that you know what you're answering
then we're gonna go back through and put
our we're going to go through and start
to draw the quantities that we see in
the problem as we see them so we'll stop
well read stop read stop and continue to
draw between those then we'll have the
bar model here and I notice I put a
demarcation here to separate my bar
model from my arithmetic so you want to
give the students some structure there
are three poorly behaved students each
student has seven demerits how many
demerits do the students have it all
there are blank demerits you know or
rather I guess the students have okay so
whilst will read through again there are
three poorly behaved students so
students there are three of them so
we'll draw three individual boxes to
represent each student each student has
seven demands so this is gonna represent
my demerits and I want to know what the
total number of demerits is in for each
student
he said that was seven how many demerits
do the students have in all so we're
looking for the total which we're going
to mark on top and again my question
mark goes where my final answer would
belong so I'm putting my question mark
here to correspond with the answer
sentence so let's go to the arithmetic I
have three students each with seven
demerits so I have
one demands you know
you